what's going on guys this is rob uh if
you guys enjoy my content make sure you
hit the subscribe button
and make sure you hit that little bell
so you never miss out on my sexy voice
continuing on with x-men disassembled uh
uncanny x-men basically it's kind of
cool again
this is like the first story arc so it's
like this big 10 part story arc that
kind of kicks off
the not really the new direction but
kind of like the return of the uncanny
x-men
and to be honest again it's pretty bold
to like kick this whole thing off with
like a giant event that basically deals
with kind of reworking everything but
nonetheless
so what we end up doing here is picking
up with the last video we basically have
x-men in possession of legion's body and
again the same thing that we talked
about in the last video is that you're
talking about
one of the most powerful probably the
single most powerful telepath
in any reality facing off against or i
guess really in possession of one of the
most powerful beings
in in the marvel universe a guy with
thousands of personalities each one
having a different power now for those
people who would question how powerful
nate grey is whether or not he's really
the most powerful telepath in any
reality
that's been stated multiple times but
one of the things that people really
point at
as the definitive statement of that is
that nate gray is basically an alternate
reality version of cable right like in
the same way that strife is like
you know a future version of cable
albeit his clone that when nate grey
first popped up and when he came to his
own reality and eventually met with
madeleine pryor who was a clone of jean
grey when she analyzed uh
nay gray she basically made the
statement that yeah he's the most
powerful telepath that any universe has
ever seen so
in the marvel multiverse when it comes
to a hierarchy of telepaths he's right
up at the top but him facing off against
the
the you know this small little
contingent of the x-men there's not a
whole lot doing here it's really him
just kind of boasting and bragging but
it's also him becoming a little bit
mad with power and the idea behind this
is that he's basically making the case
that like i don't really need
anybody in order to achieve my goal
anymore and that's true it was one thing
when nate gray just had like vast
telepathy and telekinesis at his
disposal it's another
now he has the full totality of all of
legion's abilities
with this kind of power with with the
power legion possesses i'm sorry the
power x-men possesses what you have to
bear in mind
is that while all the the various
abilities that legion has
all stem from different personalities
those personalities are in and of
themselves
effectively sentient beings meaning they
have their own motivations their own
desires and by virtue of that their own
minds and so with x-men controlling
legion he's in turn
controlling the minds of all those
personalities so he can make all those
personalities do anything he wants to do
he's in control right now of
countless abilities from reality warping
to you know time travel to
manipulating people's emotions if it's a
power you can imagine he hasn't
so the x-men facing off against him is
literally hopeless here and it's one of
these things where
everything they do every step they take
to try to defeat him is ultimately
useless
nothing really works and so what you end
up getting is jean grey kind of sending
out this sos to the entire mutant
population around the earth whatever's
left and then saying anybody who can
fight like we need you to help us fight
the reality of this
is that this is all really just sort of
trying to find a way to distract him
and the reason why is because remember
the horsemen of x-men are all
bending to his whim he's literally
controlling them with his mind and so
what they need is the ability to
basically distract him but notice this
this is when things start to get kind of
bonkers
because in this whole conflict one of
the things that happens is he literally
says well then fine
let's just change everything so what he
does is start to sink the entire
continent of north america literally
starts to sink it down into the ocean
and so of course then that basically
leads into b
showing up along with a full contingent
of the x-men and so what we basically
have here is legion
x-men facing off against all the mutants
in the marvel universe like every single
mutant in the marvel universe that can
fight
is facing off against him here and none
of them stand a chance
every single one of them are falling to
the power of legion of x-men whatever
you want to call them that's the kind of
power we're talking about here it's like
the marvel universe versus god they
never really had a chance and so the
only real option they have is to
essentially
split him and all that really resides
with storm and the reason for that is
because of how powerful storm is she's
basically the only real omega level
mutant that we have here that can
basically
attack x-men in such a way to where it
can it can offer
some measure of a distraction to allow
the telepaths in and that's why you have
like jean grey and psylocke the stepford
cuckoos basically the clones of emma
frost that's why you have them all there
is because while they could be fighting
they're going to be the means by which
that we end up seeing a split
between x-man and legion and it happens
that way because what ends up going on
here is psylocke shows up essentially
with her her
psychic shield and her psychic sword and
then in turn like grabs archangel
flies towards storm and stabs storm in
the head with this psychic dagger now
that cuts the telepathic connection and
in turn
storms back to her own accord now this
basically leads to storm like freaking
out and attacking
x-men and legion and again it's kind of
cool it's kind of storm's little shiny
moment here you know she makes a
statement you know do you think yourself
a god well i was a god but i was a
goddess before you were
even alive but again like she's a she
was a goddess in name only and that's
kind of the big difference here storm's
very very powerful she's an omega level
mutant she can control the the elements
of any planet that she's on not just
earth but she's no match for x-men
instead she was a distraction and again
what it does is it allows this
tiny sliver of a moment for the for the
telepath to essentially
break into his mind and when they do uh
it essentially allows them to like split
him in half and again it's sort of
breaking
legion away from x-men proper but in the
process x-men
yanks in jean grey now the cool thing
about this is that it could have easily
gone the direction of when now he's in
control of jean grey you know but
instead it doesn't really go that way
instead what we get is this really cool
discussion between the two where x-men
really sort of
lays out what it is that's actually
going on here and the reality of this
is that i really kind of sided with him
and let me know how you guys because i'm
curious what your all stance is about
this in terms of of who you slide with
who you think is right but it's one of
these things where jean grey says well
there's always a better way she's kind
of espousing all the stuff about xavier
there's always a better way and you can
convince people to do the right thing
but x-man stance is but like you've had
your chance to do that though like
you've had your chance to try to fix the
world quote unquote humanity has shown
itself to be incorrigible they will
always fear you and they will always
hate you and the problem is that
whenever somebody comes along with the
power to fix things you get in their way
and say we have to continue on with
xavier's dream but the idea of x-man
saying
you know really kind of speaking this is
saying but the dream is nonsense though
like it's basically it's a pacifist
standing in the face of an army that
just refuses to stop
fighting what hope does that passive is
have is tiananmen square he's gonna get
run over by a tank and so it's kind of
like okay
we have two options here you can help me
along the way or you can be destroyed
and it's kind of cool because jean's
response is i don't think you fully
understand the totality of what it is
that you're doing and creating all this
pain and suffering and so what she does
is she literally grabs the mind of
x-man and makes him witness all the
things she did as the dark phoenix and
when jean grey was a dark feeding she
did some pretty heinous things one of
the big things about the dark phoenix
story is that when when she was overcome
by emotion and the dark phoenix
literally flew out into a into a galaxy
and destroyed a system or destroyed a
star in a localized system
it killed everybody in that solar system
so billions of people's lives were
snuffed out by the actions of the dark
phoenix and when jean grey realized what
she'd done
it was a crushing sensation but it's
kind of cool here because x-man's
response is i know exactly what's gonna
happen like i know exactly the amount of
pain and suffering that i'm causing here
i've lived a life of pain and suffering
x-man was raised in the age of
apocalypse
all he'd known was experimentation all
he'd known was genetic modification all
he'd known was basically leaving one
universe where there was nothing but
pain and suffering to come to another
universe where he was the exact same
way it was just more hidden but his
response is like i'm essentially dying
here all i want to do is fix things now
this is where the scenario gets really
interesting because the question that
we've been having so far is
where in the world did he come from how
did he come back because for all intents
and purposes he was basically dead and
so it's like how did he end up getting
back here what he says is he was
resurrected by the life seed now
wind the clock back to 2011 during
rickerman's run on uncanny x-force
and one of the things reminder did is he
created the death seed and the life seed
as these two artifacts that were
basically created by the celestials and
it was sort of a way to kind of back in
and offer an explanation to like how
apocalypse was creating horsemen
different things like that the idea that
like
instead of apocalypse you know instead
of just kind of being this ambiguous
thing of he used celestial technology he
was using the death seat in order to
transform individuals into the various
horsemen that he used
and then augmenting their powers and so
on and so forth the lyfsey was created
as kind of an antithesis to the death
seat in the sense that when a person
became a horseman the only way to truly
cure them was to use the life seed the
problem is that it would destroy them as
they were
and recreate them as something new so it
was very similar to like the old siege
perilous concept from back during the
chris claremont age of the x-men but the
fact remains this is basically what
brought him back that what it did is it
resurrected nate grey and then amplified
his powers
we don't know who did this we have no
idea who it was that did this to him
presumably we'll find out somewhere
along the line but we have no idea how
that happened but with the various x-men
facing off against the physical form of
nate grey and then jean grey trying to
kind of clear things out from the inside
at the end of the day his response is
like you don't really understand what's
going on here humanity had its chance to
fix itself
mutants had their chance to basically
fix the world and all of you have
squandered your efforts
so how about i just do it for you and so
ultimately what he ends up doing is
using the full totality of his power at
his disposal and
wipes everything away and says the x-men
are gone literally eliminates the x-men
from existence and so it's
crazy because essentially because so
much of the mutant population is
composed of x-men
a vast majority of the mutant population
is now gone in response to this humanity
didn't really care they were just kind
of like okay cool so we finally got rid
of mutants that's awesome because the
mutant population is so low now
this vaccine that we had referenced in
the very beginning of the story is mass
manufactured and sent out
basically meaning that what few x-men or
i guess mutants exist out there now are
basically having their powers removed
now again we do have more than 198 but
we're talking about maybe a couple
thousand
not nearly as many as there were before
the whole events of house of m but again
you're talking about a very small
percentage of the population with your
mutants most of which have been wiped
out by x-men but i'm sorry by x-men and
in turn uh the rest are basically being
eliminated but the crazy thing about
this this is the big takeaway from the
story the crazy thing about this is that
going into this event
age of x one of the things we end up
finding out here is that cyclops has
been resurrected from the dead
the cyclops is back now and so we have
no idea what in the world this means
like it's cool but basically
it'll more or less see the return of
like the x-men as we knew them before
the events of
marvel trying to make the inhumans cool
which didn't work because the inhumans
have always sucked but it's interesting
here and i'm really curious to see where
we end up going in like the whole age of
x event but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you